this podcast has bad words
you know let's talk about
some of the best apps for decluttering
your home this article came up during
the research that
i was doing here and you and i have not
gone through this totally so i thought i
would read it to you for the first time
and we can just comment so these they'll
put a link to this in the show notes as
well this is from fast company these are
five great apps
that can help declutter your home and
your life
yeah i want to throw like caution out
right now yes so like no app is going to
fix all your problems in fact it might
cause more problems right this is the
palliative care versus the cure yeah and
so if you don't understand the why and
you start heaping some apps onto you
it's like imagine i'm going to download
an app that helps me manage my apps
right exactly okay like i i get it and
maybe some of these things will add
value to your life yeah but always be
cautious about taking on more to deal
with your problem of more right it makes
me think of uh
you know people who are
needing help with their finances
and they're constantly buying books
you know maybe it's how to get rich
maybe it's how to manage your finances
maybe it's you know financial course
whatever it is these are all tools that
certainly could help
yes but there's there might be a certain
point where you have to accept that like
spending more money on something isn't
going to help your finance financial
problems yeah
what is the occult term that we talk
about in a lot of people use things is i
used to hear this you have to spend
money to make money and like i believed
that because people said it with
confidence right what the hell does that
even mean
i don't know
i mean you could just end it you have to
spend money
yeah that would that would make sense
right yeah if you spend money
it's like that remember that south park
episode where like it was like uh steel
underpants question mark profit yeah
that's sort of the same equation there
it was like
i don't know how we're gonna make money
by spending money
but i'm not going to question it because
someone said it with real authority yeah
right anyway here's the first app
see what you've got and get rid of it
with
bye bye
i thought i said ribeye at first which
is a strange name for an app
like b-e-b-e yep yeah the free
buy buy de-clutter app helps you
straighten up by providing a checklist
of things to get rid of you create lists
and add them
by snapping quick photos of items when
finished you can add text to each how
often used the cost other notes to get a
clear view of all you have so you may no
longer need toggling a regret slider oh
okay so there's like a little slider on
there that if you regret having the item
well then maybe that's uh an indication
to let go dude this sounds this stresses
me out thinking about it me too
cataloging all your items basically
this to me is is a type of hoarding in a
way and so i'm not recommending the buy
buy app because
it is now you're hoarding your things
not just physically but also digitally
yeah and we're also not not recommending
it it's just great point for you and i
is it doesn't make much sense right i'm
sure there's someone out there who gets
a ton of value out of it the easiest way
to declutter your stuff is to get rid of
most of it not to catalog it you are not
a museum
right now i get it if now maybe this app
here let's think of a case where it
would be useful ryan maybe it's useful
but if you've simplified your life and
now you are at a point where you're like
okay i feel like i've i've gotten rid of
80 of my possessions i feel freer and
and there's still some things i'm not
really sure yeah about i could see that
yeah you know i mean imagine catalog
three cataloging three hundred thousand
items it's gonna take you forever why
why do that but if now you've gotten it
down to your 288 items that you own
okay i could see where you're like okay
you know what some of these i still
don't want maybe this will help me with
that yeah the next one is called sweepy
keep it clean with sweepy sweepy is an
app that helps you create cleaning
schedules to keep your home clean and
tidy it shows how to split household
chores among family members that can be
really helpful especially a big family
right for sure it shows
family members and even rewards with
effort points to encourage a little
harmless competition well i don't know
about that part i don't know there's
such thing as harmless competition but
maybe there is
the next app is called
adobe scan app so purge your papers with
adobe scan
nothing clutters up a house quite like
piles of aging paperwork to the rescue
the excellent and free adobe scan app
which uses your phone's camera to create
high quality pdfs as easily as taking a
photo i use apple notes feature which
does the same thing now and so you can
use that you can use the adobe scan app
as well
next is subdue your subscriptions with
unroll.me now someone's actually going
to ask about this in the future some on
later on this episode in fact i'm going
to talk about some of the problems
potentially with unroll.me and some
alternatives to unroll.me so it's not
something i necessarily recommend we'll
talk about that in a bit and finally
there's an app called thumbtack
can't someone else do it is the tagline
here time is money and decluttering is
awful
yeah i agree with both of those well
time is time and sometimes it costs you
money and decluttering can be awful
especially if you're doing it on your
own it's overwhelming that's why i don't
recommend decluttering i recommend
getting rid of the things yeah so
which ends up being
quite a potential potent combination for
some people for those of you who want to
get organized but just don't have the
time willpower or wherewithal there's
thumbtack the free app connects people
to
the free app connects people who need
help with professional service providers
such as handymen house cleaners painters
or you guessed it professional
organizers so and you can see who's
available in your area how much they
charge
reviews by former clients and more this
one can be really helpful however
let's be cautious about this one as well
people ask us all the time we're out on
tour and they'll come up to us and hey
you know while you're in town what if i
paid you guys to come over to my house
and and help us organize and it's like
well no there's two reasons why no
because i hate doing that i don't want
to do it my own house let alone yours
and and second i can declutter your
closet for you but it's going to be
re-cluttered a month from now yeah a
year from now yeah if you let someone
else do the work then it's not going to
be nearly as meaningful and you're not
going to get those lessons out of it yes
like that packing party it was awesome
for you to come over and help me pack
stuff up but you know when i had to like
get rid of all of it and um yeah pull
stuff out i mean if if you would have
done it for me a like it wouldn't have
been uh
it would have been to my taste it would
have been to your taste right in fact i
remember there was a certain point where
you were like sweeping a bunch of coffee
mugs into a garbage bag yeah because
it's really easy to throw away somebody
else's stuff you had a lot of you had
like 30 something coffee mug that's
ridiculous well hey i drink coffee
isn't that how we justify everything
though and by the way you didn't buy all
30 of those one day right you get one in
an event or you buy one at a store or
whatever and all of a sudden before you
know it seven eight years later now you
have 30 coffee mugs because you never
stop to question any of those coffee
mugs right yeah and so yes you can hire
professionals to do certain things i
mean we certainly hire professionals to
do things in the studio with the
lighting and the artwork and things like
that but the question is if you have a
burden dealing with that burden it's
probably going to be most beneficial for
you long term if you personally deal
with that
that burden and if you need help
get someone that you know to help you or
hire a professional but they help you
they don't do it for you yeah did you
enjoy this video if so you can listen to
full episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free